picking some yarrow here I'm going to
make some SAP for my hands feet and my
dog's feet dog's feet get in the cold
conditions that we run them in they get
kind of dry and this helps to keep them
supple and soft it's very important to
be knowledgeable about the things that
grow in our area here because medicine
is expensive this is proactive health
care I got some wormwood that I picked
the other day gonna be my sab puck this
is what I'm gonna fill up and I'll set
this inside with boiling water and this
pretty central whenever you do what I do
out in the winter to be able to start a
fire with the simplest of means this
yarrow has a lot of medicinal properties
and septic anti-inflammatory and
antibacterial get back to the fire yeah
let's do it
water starting to get hot to go overly
hot want to fit a fair amount of oil in
there so I end up with a quite a bit of
good product
I'm gonna have a nice product here good
medicine I can use in my dog's feet can
use it on these bee stings that I got
before I jar it where I'll lose that
beeswax beeswax is what gives you the
consistency for yourself otherwise it
would just be an oil not a sound
sometimes I'm running the fish net my
hands get all sore and I'll crack in you
know in the winter I'm doing the stuff
outside I mean I gotta have some focus
beautiful no I got myself a good case of
salve started for the winter for the
dogs but right now you know my hands are
beat up and I got these stings and I'm
gonna try some out myself
it feels great after a hard day's work